welcome to the show everybody obviously
there's quite a lot happening in the
world today in the country we're gonna
talk about all of that lots of important
news but I want to begin by discussing
something even more important than any
of that namely myself
well not myself exactly but my book I
did just announced yesterday that I have
a new book coming out being released
February 25th but you can pre-order it
now and I would ask that you do
pre-order it rather than waiting to the
last minute you're damn procrastinators
the book is called Church of cowards and
it brings together in one volume my
thoughts on the subject I've spoken
about often on this show written about
and that is the problem of apathy
cowardice and complacency in the church
and and this is a problem that cannot be
pinned entirely on church leadership on
on the so called Christian leaders in
the country and throughout the world
though obviously of course there's a
significant portion of blame that goes
to them and I talked about that in the
book but this is also an issue that
implicates everybody me you everyone I
don't think any of us are are entirely
innocent so I try not to spare anybody
in this book myself included and I hope
you'll give it a read Church of cowards
go to Amazon look it up buy the book
before it comes out On February 25th ok
speaking of bad leadership the Democrat
Party continues to continues to somehow
make the Republican party look like it
has it scrap together by comparison
which if you've been following politics
for any length of time that is an
incredible accomplishment that's a
remarkable feat to be able to do that as
you know as you as you probably know
doubt heard by now the Iowa caucuses
were last night somehow they managed
after three years of preparation to
completely bungle it the night ended
with no winner no results nothing which
threw everybody into disarray including
the media which led to and I want to
play this just at the at the the front
of the show because I think this is one
this is a great moment a great moment in
media was was this right here watch this
Sean Sebastian joining us right now from
storey County is a precinct secretary
out there what can you tell us about
this delay in getting any results Joan
well wolf I have been on hold
over an hour with the Iowa Democratic
Party they tried
I think promote an app to report the
results the app by all accounts just
like doesn't work so we've been
recommended to call into the hotline and
the hotline has not been responsive any
explanation as to what's going on no no
I'm just waiting on hold and doing my
best to report the results from
everything what are you hearing I know
you're listening to a conversation from
the Iowa Democratic Party this is a real
coincidence wolf I just got off hold
just so I've got to get off the phone to
report the results all right go ahead
reporters what can we listen in as your
report them John yep all right okay hi
hello they hung up on me okay I've got
to get back in line on hold so
frustrating indeed now on one hand I
really love that that's that's it's it's
good stuff but on the other I feel for
that guy I feel I can relate to it
especially as a parent because this has
definitely happen to me before where I'm
waiting on hold with Comcast or somebody
for 45 minutes and then after 45 minutes
my kids come into the room and they
distract me and I'm telling them to you
know I'm yelling at them and then in the
melee the rep the customer rep comes on
the phone but I'm distracted and he
takes the opportunity to just hang up so
and of course in this analogy Wolf
Blitzer would be like my kids so that
was that was fun though
but the utter incompetence of the
Democratic Party here and not just here
but over the past three years and beyond
does lead us to I think to a more
serious perhaps ominous point and I want
to talk about that in just a moment but
first you know one of the most important
things in your home
is not only to be safe but to feel safe
to feel secure in your home I think if
you don't have not have not being able
to feel secure in your home it's it's
something that robs you of peace of mind
and that's that's not good at all and
that's why rings mission is to make
neighborhoods safer and to make you
safer and feel safer in your home you
might have already you might already
know about their smart video doorbells
and cameras that protect millions of
people everywhere ring helps you stay
connected to your home anywhere in the
world so if there's a package delivery
or a surprise visit you'll get an alert
you'll know and then you could talk to
the person no matter where you are and
so this is not just about say - tell us
about convenience of being able to being
able to answer the door essentially even
if you're not in the home or even if you
can't get to the door you could be 3,000
miles away you could still answer the
door and this there's that convenience
there but I you know I can't emphasize
enough the peace of mind aspect of it
which especially for me and I've got
four kids I've got a wife family in the
house and so that's one of the reasons
that I have ring as a subscriber you
have a special offer and a ring welcome
kit available right now at ring comm
slash Walsh the kit includes a video
doorbell and a chime Pro which is just
just what you need to a start building a
ring of protection around your home
today go to ring comm slash Walsh
that's ring.com slash Walsh okay so
there are a few lessons that we can
learn I think from the disastrous
beginning of the Democrat party's
primary process a process that as they
boasted in a tweet on Monday afternoon
they'd spent the last three years
preparing for that's what they said and
you know the pilot of the Hindenburg
also spent time preparing but all of
preparation in the world can't
compensate for incompetent execution so
somehow after the build up Monday night
ended without a winner or any results at
all and it's it seems part of the
problem is that the Democrats decided to
hand the facilitation and management of
its primary in Iowa over to a secretive
firm in DC called literally shadow Inc
so that's literally the name of the
organization shadow Inc which is a bit
like sending your children to a daycare
center
like child neglect LLC so I can only I
just I just imagine the you know the
bosses of the Democrat Party in the
offices of shadow Inc and there's a guy
you know sitting at his desk with his
with his chair turned around looking out
the window his back to them puffing uh
cigar stroking a cat and they say yeah I
think this this is a guy this is the guy
that needs to handle our primaries and
these are the sorts of unforced errors
that the the Democrats can't seem to
stop themselves from making as they
continue as I said to achieve the
remarkable feat of making the Republican
Party look good somehow now of course I
may be giving them too much credit when
I say that this is an error I I'm not
sure that this that this debacle can be
called an error necessarily because that
categorization assumes that there's no
deliberate corruption at work here and
that's probably not a safe assumption
especially given the Democrats track
record with primaries but all at all
this amounts to more good news for
Donald Trump who is a man that has been
blessed with the most important and
ineffectual adversaries that probably
the world has ever seen this is Donald
Trump is so fortunate he that God has
blessed him with these with these
buffoons as his enemies
and as as many of us have been saying
for four years now ever since Trump came
on the scene especially ever since he
became president all the Democrats
really have to do is just be basically
normal and sane and and that's and that
probably be enough to get the edge and
to win in 2020 it's all we need to do
and and they can't even do that
they that really that that bar as low as
it is they're not able to get over that
bar which which means that you know that
that I think the possibility of Trump
still losing to these blundering clowns
is that possibility that seems less and
less likely with each passing day but if
he does lose to them this is an ominous
warning I think for the future because
we should keep in mind that these people
who cannot figure out how to operate
their own primary also want to operate
the entire health care system Bernie
Sanders and Elizabeth Warren in
particular had promised a complete
government takeover of health care
in fact Sanders is on record saying that
he wants he's advocating a complete
government takeover of all industry of
all major industry he has said this
specifically explicitly now he he was he
hasn't been he hasn't been quite that
explicit in recent years but this is
what he said back in his 30s I think it
was back when he was 35 or 36 he's on
record saying the government should take
over all major industries now if we had
a real media they'd be following up with
with that and saying hey does that still
what you want to do let me think about
you we've got a Democrat candidate who
very well could win the nomination who's
that who's in the past advocated for a
government takeover of all major
industries and nobody in the media is
asked him about it and this by the way
is full-blown communism not communism in
the loose kind of pejorative sense that
people use it but actual literal
communism Bernie Sanders is an actual
communist so this is the communism of
Soviet Russia and Pol Pot and and many
of the the most evil and blood-drenched
regimes of the 20th century that's that
is the ideology that that in the
government the governing philosophy that
he aligns himself with and but he's not
asked about it by the media which is
really incredible
and I think this this this latter fact
the fact that
seen how communism works
other countries especially in the in the
in the bloodiest deadliest
century in human history in the 20th
century because of communism so that
should be enough to cause us to run far
and fast away from any candidate who
advocates a full government takeover of
any industry let alone the healthcare
industry let alone every other industry
as well as the healthcare industry but
if the twentieth century is too far in
the past
to make an impression somehow then I
think this monday is lesson enough in
order for the plans proposed by Sanders
Warren and and company to have any
appeal we first have to place our trust
in the skill and competency and
integrity of government bureaucrats and
this is the part you notice this is the
part of the case that the socialists
never bother trying to make yes they can
tell a harrowing tale about all the
evils of capitalism and the problems of
free of the free market and they can
convince you to look with suspicion on
corporations and the dreaded
billionaires and I don't even
necessarily disagree with them on that
point then in a way we should be
suspicious of corporations we shouldn't
just blindly trust them you know if
you've got if you've got one of these
tech companies asking you to hand your
privacy over to them which most of us
have already done but we shouldn't trust
our privacy with them and all of our
sensitive information so that part fine
but then there's the next part
never get around to explaining why
trust them the politicians instead
and and that's because I don't think
even they could make that argument with
a straight face
and this again goes back to to
malpractice by the media which is a very
intentional malpractice
you're gonna let Bernie Sanders stand up
there all day at debates and in any of
use and so on talking about the problem
with with capitalism and and
billionaires and why they shouldn't have
control over this and that nobody ever
stops asked him ok but why should you
control it though why should we trust
you
should we trust bureaucrats what's the
reason give us a what give us one good
reason that's all I'm asking for one
good reason why we should trust
bureaucrats instead
well because the billionaires no I
didn't ask about the billionaires that's
not what I'm asking
let's go from the billionaires to the
bureaucrats why should we trust them one
good reason that's it just give me one
and don't tell me because they're
they're subject to elections they're not
our government is massively massively
enormous ly gargantuan it monstrous huge
and and nine
percent of the people in the government
who work for the government probably
more than 99 percent are not elected so
they can't make the argument
and besides which we've all been to the
DMV so we know how the government works
and this week is just the latest example
and that I think is the the highlight
and the point of this madness in Iowa
there are some people trying to make it
a point about well this is why Iowa
shouldn't be the first primary in the
country and this is why we need to
change the way we do primaries I don't I
don't disagree with that either by the
way but that's not really the point
though on an almost unrelated note I do
agree that it doesn't make any sense to
me why Iowa arbitrarily gets this gets
this privileged position where they're
the decision they make in the primary
has all of this enormous weight Iowa New
Hampshire Iowa New Hampshire right it's
like all that really matters is them and
then and then you have states that by
the time they go it's already been
decided so I don't see how that makes
any sense
at a minimum if we're gonna know I you
know there's there's a part of me that
would be sympathetic to a call for a
national primary where you do all the
primaries on the same day now the
argument against that is that then well
there are a few arguments one of them is
that it would make it a lot harder for
the lesser known candidates who need
that staggered process to build momentum
if you just do it all on one day then
really the just the most famous most
well known candidates gonna win every
time okay I get that but if you're gonna
do the staggered thing where we're
holding these these primaries over the
course of many weeks there's no reason
why one state should always go first and
always have this this this
disproportionate influence over the way
the rest of the primary goes there's no
reason for that other than its tradition
okay well just because it's tradition
doesn't mean we keep doing it forever
without ever stopping okay let's let's
move on
you know the the Guardian and the daily
wire have both reported on an exciting
new business venture that I wanted to
mention and this is for the low price of
just $2,500 to particularly industrious
race hustlers will come to your house
eat your food and call you a racist this
is a real business and this is not some
sort of strange masochistic sexual
fetish as far as I know it is it's an
opportunity for white people to learn
that they are abysmal sacks of garbage
if you didn't already know so it's kind
of like a self empowerment thing but but
the opposite of that the opposite of
self empowerment
let me read them this is the Guardian
explaining this business it says a white
woman volunteers to host a dinner in her
home for seven other white women often
strangers perhaps acquaintances each
dinner cost $2,500 which can be covered
by a generous host or divided among
guests a frank discussion is led by
co-founders Regina Jackson who is black
and Saira Rao who identifies as Indian
American they started race to dinner to
challenge liberal white women to accept
their racism however subconscious if you
did this in a conference room they leave
Rao says but healthy white women have
been taught never or but wealthy white
women have been taught never to leave
the dinner table so this is a service
yes offered offered only to white women
unfortunately white men are irredeemable
The Guardian says Rao and Jackson
believe white liberal women are the most
receptive audience because they are open
to changing their behavior they don't
bother with the 53% of white women who
voted for Trump white men they feel are
similarly a lost cause Jackson says
quote white men are never going to
change anything if they were they would
have done it by now and then here's an
inspiring example of one such white
woman finally admitting and accepting
that she is essentially Hitler Allison
goob sir says recently I've been driving
around seeing a black person and having
an assumption that they're up to no good
immediately after that I'm like that's
no good this is a human just doing their
thing why do I think that because of
course you know it's only white people
who engage in the
sort of negative stereotyping other
races of people they never do this ever
doesn't happen only white right now
we're told that they've conducted 15 of
these dinners at 2,500 a pop so that net
tolst almost 40 grand they've made not a
bad business plan especially when you
consider this is nearly all profit I
guess the only real overhead is is the
only cost that they incur I imagine are
the medical treatments for their vocal
cords after they spend a whole evening
shouting racist in the faces of cowering
soccer moms so I must say and I was
thinking about this you know I I find
their efforts inspiring and so inspiring
that in keeping with the traditions of
my people of white men I'm going to
appropriate this idea now I have no
doubt and and I don't mean to cast
aspersions here I have no doubt that the
certified haranguing offered by these
two women is well worth the money but
why spend more than you have to and this
is where I'm you know this is me I
announced a book and so now this is a
business new business I'm opening that
I'm excited to announce as well so it's
kind of a big a big day for me for a
number of reasons here's my business
model I would be willing to perform the
exact same service at half the price
okay so for a measly 1250 $1,250 that's
it I'll sit at your table Gorge on your
food and ceaselessly belittle you
now here's what I'm saying don't pay
full price for a scolding when you could
get a perfectly acceptable scolding for
half of that it just it doesn't make any
sense financially that's what I'm trying
to say and don't think for a second that
my accusations and my insults that I
hurl at you will be tamer just because
I'm the bargain bin option and I
understand like a good wedding DJ you
have to play the hits so that means of
course I'm gonna call you a racist I'm
gonna call you a sexist I'm gonna call
you a transfer I'm gonna call you a
homophobe etc etc but I'll thick I'll
even mix in a few of the more
cutting-edge s and phobes that maybe you
haven't heard of so after my dinner you
may discover that you're not only an
ageist ethnocentric just normative by
phobe but also a goober phob you know
what a goober phob is a goober phob is
someone who is discriminatory against
gay Oberer drivers okay that's a real
thing that I just made up but this is
this is a kind of ingenuity that I bring
to it and it gets better because for a
small let's say 75 dollar up charge I'll
also yell at your pets and you have to
think about this because you are racist
scum as we've established do you think
your pets have not absorbed any of that
any of your bigot fumes see living with
you is like is like it's like living
near Chernobyl the toxicity radiates off
of you and infects everything in the
vicinity so after I finished with you
dinner I'll go to your you know dog I'll
go to the hamster I'll go to the
goldfish whatever and I'll scream at
them and it'll be a very cleansing
experience for them as well and so once
my session is complete everybody in the
house is gonna feel like a total dirt
that is my guarantee or your money back
just kidding of course I would never
give money back to a racist so look out
for that as I as I bring that business
to the masses now a couple of things to
talk about but first a quick message
about this show as you know we rely in
part on our advertisers to keep the mic
hot and the lights on and one thing
that's really important to us is that we
know who's listening and it's how we
make sure that we're featuring
advertisers that you guys actually want
to do business with so if you have just
a few minutes to spare I would really
appreciate if you could visit the pod
survey dot-com that's the pod survey com
to fill out a shirt short survey about
yourself once we have enough data that
helps us find advertisers who you want
to hear from so this is just all about
you know what kind of things you're
interested in and and all of that so
visit the pond survey com it'll take
just a few minutes and you know you got
five minutes of spare don't you you're
not doing anything none of us are with
our lives complete the survey to help my
team bring you advertisers that you
really want and need to hear from okay
I've been want to talk about this issue
for a few few days now and now now I
will it's a story that hasn't gotten a
lot of attention Michele Carter no no if
you remember the name she was released
from prison last week after serving 11
months in jail 11 months Carter as you
may or may not recall was the sociopath
who repeatedly encouraged her suicidal
boyfriend to kill himself and then when
he did at her urging she told no one
pretended to be shocked and saddened and
had apparently done the whole thing to
get attention this was according to the
prosecutors and she was convicted this
was all a ploy because she wanted
sympathy and attention and so she
managed she decided to get that by
manipulating her boyfriend into killing
himself now this is a case that has
really stuck with me because I think it
stuck with a lot of people it's just
because it's it's just how absolutely
evil this is it's the kind of case that
sends chills right down to your bones in
a way that some other
bad cases don't quite to the same degree
because this this gives you a unique
look into the depths of human evil I
mean let's recall what this girl did
this was not her saying once kill
yourself out of anger or half joking or
something like that that's not what this
was this was not her putting kill
yourself in the comment section under
under a YouTube video we're sending it
in an email to a podcast host she
doesn't like that some of this was this
was a depressed boyfriend and who came
to his girlfriend for you know for
emotional support and instead her
girlfriend repeatedly over a period of
time methodically tried to break his
will break him down and get him to kill
himself including berating and insulting
him for not doing it and on the night
when he did it she was on the phone with
him berating him for trying to back out
he wanted to back out at the last minute
and she was urging him insisting that he
do it
when he did and was dead she didn't call
anybody didn't tell anybody
certainly didn't try to get a medical
treatment of course and just pretended
to be shocked and sad and everything
when she heard the news now incredibly
in my view there are plenty of people
who've defended this person the
girlfriends the Carter or at least if
not defended her said that at a minimum
she shouldn't go to jail people have
even tried to make this a free speech
issue which is what her defense team
argued and I understand her defense team
arguing it that's that's that's the only
defense they could possibly offer and so
they did but if you're not one of her
lawyers III don't understand
arguing that free speech really and this
only proves my point that free speech
has come to mean almost nothing all of
the freedoms and rights we talked about
it's it's as I discussed at length
yesterday it these these phrases mean
almost nothing now but nobody knows what
they mean no one can define them we just
throw them out there randomly to make a
point and that's what's happening here
trying to manipulate a suicidal
depressive into killing himself he's not
free speech and I can't believe I even
have to say that by the way if you think
it is and this is absolutely inescapable
if you think that what she did is
covered under free speech then you have
to argue that Charles Manson never
should have gone to prison because
Charles Manson many people don't know
this never killed anybody
no he brainwashed his groupies into
killing people he didn't do it himself
yet he went to jail for life until death
which is how a life in prison works now
I would say that's clearly not free
speech when you take mentally unbalanced
people and you urge them try to get them
to kill somebody
that's not free speech that's that's
that's murder that's why I would say
but if you're gonna tell me that it's
that it's free speech for this girl to
manipulate her mentally unstable
boyfriend into killing himself then you
have to argue that Charles Manson was
covered under free speech when he
manipulated mentally understate unstable
people into killing other people III
just I logically inescapable but of
course with Charles Manson nobody would
argue that because it's totally crazy
and what exactly are people worried
about that this is a slippery slope I've
heard that I was talking about this on
social media this this weekend and some
people wish I had a slippery slope you
know a slippery slope into what into
some sort of dystopian horror scape
where where you could no longer tell
people to kill themselves
oh the oh the humanity how horrible that
would be that's not even where this is
headed at all because she embarked on a
campaign a long campaign to manipulate
him into into killing himself this was
not a one-off thing this was not a
moment of passion and her just saying
kill yourself
obviously if she had done that she
wouldn't go into jail it's not what this
was so this is this is not heading to a
place where you're not allowed to leave
a youtube comment telling someone to
kill themselves that's not where this is
headed but my point is even if it was
heading there who cares is that is that
Raley's like would you be oppressed and
persecuted if you lived in a country
where you can't tell people online to
kill themselves
how would that harm you in any way
whatsoever in any case manipulating a
man into killing himself so you can get
attention
I would say horribly evil and this is a
dangerous person
she gets out of jail if you don't think
she's dangerous what do you think's
gonna happen when she has kids
how's that gonna go when you have
somebody this emotionally manipulative
we're Anna sociopath a psychopath who
only cares about attention to themselves
and they've got kids how do you think
that's going to go
Munchausen by proxy what do you think
that is
that's a parent making a child sick or
causing the child to think that he's
sick so that the parent can get
attention
so that's where this is headed this is a
dangerous person 11 months in jail
she gets out
now you cannot convince me that the fact
that she's a blonde chick didn't held
her because I would say it absolutely
did I don't really see any scenario can
you imagine
let's reverse the genders for a moment
let's say you've got a man over a period
of many months manipulating a mentally
unbalanced depressive woman into killing
herself can you imagine a man getting
out of jail in 11 months
now granted she was only she was only
sentenced to 15 months which is bad
enough as it is
she didn't even serve the whole year can
you imagine that with a man I can't this
is where female privilege comes in this
is a real thing this is not they've done
Studies on this
the statistics are right there you can
go look them up yourself
women get I think on average on average
men get sentences that are 63% like 652
it's 8:52 6 dealing I want to say 63% is
a number it's on top of my head here but
they get the men on average for the same
crimes get significantly longer
sentences than women do and that's even
when controlling for factors like
previous criminal history ok so it's not
like while the men get longer sentences
because they've got a track record now
even when controlling for those sorts of
things women get significantly shorter
sentences and in fact men are twice as
likely to get sent to prison in the
first place
meaning in many cases the women don't
you in many in many situations there are
crimes where if a man commits it he goes
to jail for a period of time if a woman
commits it she doesn't go to jail at all
so that is that's that's feeb that is
actual female privilege that is really
happening systemically we hear so much
about systemic bigotry and systemic this
this is systemic it's in the justice
system systemic discrimination against
men in favor of women and you just you
can't convince me that this is not an
example of that I think I think it very
clearly is so we'll get to emails in
just a second here but first I want to
tell you about this offer we have this
has been quite a year already
what a year this month has been this has
been I feel like I've aged about six
years already in 2020 and it's only been
it's only been a little over a month and
the election race is just getting
started god help us the best way to stay
informed and on top of all of this is to
become a daily wire member with 20% off
your membership that's 20% off all new
what new daily wiring memberships when
using promo code DW 2020 members get our
articles ad free you get access to all
of our live broadcast the show library
with full three hours of Ben Shapiro
show every day
select bonus content access to the
mailbag and now our new all-access TR
gets gets you into live online Q&A
discussions like the one being hosted
tonight after tonight which is backstage
state-of-the-union ben shapiro andrew
Clavin michael knowles and god king
jeremy boring we'll be streaming at 8:30
p.m. 5:30 that's 8:30 Eastern 5:30
Pacific to bring you Trump's speech live
with their analysis subscriber questions
and followed by an exclusive online Q&A
over at daily wired.com slash
discussions again that's promo code DW
2024 20% off trust me you don't want to
miss it
alright let's go to emails Matt well
show at gmail.com Matt well show at
gmail.com it says from Curt says Matt
very dumb question but I hope I'm hoping
you can give me a simple explanation
what exactly is a caucus how does it
work how should it work I know the Iowa
situation is a mess but how is it
supposed to go seriously I've never
understood it well Kurt you're right
this is a rather dumb question I'm
afraid caucuses like the one in Iowa
putting aside all the the
debacle that happen it's it's a it's a
pretty simple process and I can't
believe you don't understand it I don't
mean to you know I don't mean to judge
you or anything but fine I'll explain it
you see and I can easily explain it to
you and it goes like this I'll explain
it right now in fact what happens as it
proceeds the caucus is that there are
actually well essentially decisions okay
are made and let's just say basically
what it comes down to when in fact it's
all said and done at the end of the day
is that determinations are made all
right important determinations and those
determinations are at the conclusion of
a process let's call it they're going to
lead to the formulation of what you
might even call results and those
results are really I'm gonna tell you
who wins okay so do you understand
that's as as simple as I can put it okay
because I definitely understand how
caucuses work myself this is from Carlos
says hello Matt yesterday the Super Bowl
was a good game not as exciting without
my Patriots on it but I'm glad the
Chiefs won I saw that people were
accusing you of being anti Latino for
saying that the halftime show was
inappropriate however as a Hispanic born
in Latin America myself I agree with you
if anything what I find offensive is
their implication that our Latin culture
can be reduced to that garbage a show of
over sexualized 50 year old women
stripping and pole dancing on the stage
is not representative of Latin culture
everybody white Hispanic or otherwise
should be free to say so it is a shame
because Shakira wasn't too bad back when
she started in Colombia before she went
full hollywood around 2008 thank you and
keep up the good work well thanks Carlos
and it yeah it's funny because I noticed
perhaps unsurprisingly that many of the
people who were making the argument that
it's anti Latino or racist or whatever
to criticize the halftime show
we're not Latino themselves so once
again we have the bigotry of low
expectations on display here which is
very common among liberal white people
where they you know I mean imagine
imagine being you know non-latino just a
white person like me and arguing that
strip shows and simulated orgies are
Latin culture what are you actually
saying about Latin culture and how is
that a defense of Latin culture and not
an attack on it so that's that's kind of
the with these with these liberal white
Saviour types that's the kind of
patronizing undertone which you can
hardly even call an undertone because
they sort of smack you in the face with
it it's so obvious and explicit but what
they're saying is oh no we you know we
can't expect I'm here arguing let's have
some basic decency that's all as I said
yesterday
let's have basic decency I'm not saying
that everything on TV has to be
appropriate for kids all the time
obviously not you turn on premium
channels at 10:00 p.m. you turn on HBO
or something I'm not asking for that to
be appropriate for kids obviously it
won't be and I'm not even asking that
the halftime show be tailored for kids
okay I'm not mad I'm not asking that you
have the Wiggles performers that's the
last thing I'd want to say in fact but
just basic decent just keep in mind that
families are watching and don't go out
of your way to be wildly offensive and
inappropriate that's what I'm arguing
and when a white person comes in and
says oh no we can't expect that they're
a different culture we can't expect that
of them
I cannot think of a more racist
sentiment than that okay let's go to
Paul says you win the Internet I hate
this phrase in all variations of it it
is stupid your thoughts well Paul I got
to say you win the internet for that
email I agree with you
this is just one of dozens of phrases
and memes that represent to me a
person's inability to form original
thoughts if you want to communicate to
someone that you like what they posted
on the Internet instead of using this
phrase which has been used six billion
times before just use your own distinct
voice and describe how you feel in a way
that is not this this this cliche I
don't even know what's the point like if
you're gonna comment under something on
the internet and say you win the
Internet why even say it what's the
point of even saying it you you it's
already been said a million times
so this is why under my regime you win
the Internet will be a banned phrase
along with many other overused internet
phrases and jargon such as you hate to
see it
yikes just gonna leave this here checks
notes sorry this is happening - you said
no one ever let that sink in hold my
beer sir this is a Wendy's let's be
clear
shots fired I'll take blank for a
thousand Alex
full stop don't at me this period this
didn't age well asking for a friend
arty if you agree I'll wait big if true
louder for the people in the back I
don't know who I don't know who needs to
hear this but clap back bruh I'm dead
I'm old enough to remember when okay
boomer raise your hand if delete your
account hard pass hot take tbh the thing
repiy
repeat the same phrase over and over in
all caps you can't make this up and then
so all those are banned internet phrases
now and then by a mile my most hated is
you're really gonna die on this hill I
hate that one the most because it's so
it is so incredibly overused and
painfully unoriginal but it's also this
this way of mocking someone for
committing the sin of having a
conviction of some kind and it also
implies that every opinion somebody
expresses is somehow the most important
thing in the world to them and they're
taking some kind of last stand to defend
it it is just a boring bland kind of
cynicism where someone expresses an idea
and and you're just sitting there going
basically yeah whatever that that's
essentially what it is because you're
gonna die on this hill it is almost
always used specifically for people who
share a counterintuitive or original
opinion and it's a way of trying to shut
down that opinion which is the last
thing we should be doing I don't
understand people who react so harshly
to original ideas you know I'm at the
point where I don't even care what the
original idea is it doesn't even matter
to me if you if you can if you're on the
internet or anywhere in life sharing an
original opinion I'm gonna I want to
hear you out I want to hear it I don't
care what it is
because I am so sick to death and tired
of the same old thing and the same old
talking points from everybody all the
time about everything so that you know
oh you're really gonna die on this hill
I get that all the time as you may may
not surprise you to learn especially
when I'm talking about some kind of more
minor thing and and and and as oh oh
you're gonna die on this hill
well according to people I've died on
about 6 million Hills and yet I'm still
standing so no I don't think I'm dying
on a hill I think I'm just expressing a
point of view the other day I made the
point I've made this point probably
plenty of times in past because it is
important that you shouldn't you you
shouldn't use ketchup with your fries
then if you using ketchup with your
fries that's an indication that your
fries are not well seasoned if you have
well seasoned fries then ketchup
actually dulls the the seasoning in the
fries and it's it's is a Lizzie it's
it's not as rich have an experience
anymore and so you shouldn't use fry a
ketchup is really for children it's not
for adults that's the point I mean and I
someone said are you gonna die on this
hill how am i dying on a hill of ketchup
I'm just saying this is just my opinion
about cattle you don't have to care you
don't have to agree I'm not standing
here taking some last desperate stand
with my dying breath saying don't need
ketchup I wouldn't put it past me to
make that the thing I say in my last
words my last words probably will be
something petty and stupid like that but
still that's not really what I'm doing
right now
alright let's go one last email here
this is from Dan Matt I think you're
contradicting yourself you complained at
length about the inappropriate halftime
show and said your kids should be able
to watch the game with you but other
times I've heard you say of people who
complain about your social media content
that they can just unfollow you and
about your show that they can just stop
listening so why can't you just stop
watching and turn the channel
why [ __ ] about it you're really going
to die on this hill Dan
really
well there are there are a number of
differences then first of all I think
there's a rather obvious distinction
between an expressed opinion which is
all I ever do
expressing opinions and something like
objectionable sexual content so your
comparison would make sense if I was
rather than sharing opinions on my
podcast and on social media if I was
sorry to put this image in your head but
if I was stripping on my podcast if I
was doing my podcast from a stripper
pole uh and then complaining about JLo
at halftime then maybe you'd have a case
but I'm not all I'm doing is talking
about ideas second actually you wouldn't
even have a case even then even if I was
stripping on my podcast you still
wouldn't have a case because my point is
that there should be spaces in society
that are appropriate for children I
think that a football game the biggest
TV event of the year is such a space or
should be it is such a space because you
have to go out of your way to make it
not appropriate to take away that space
from children if you just played the
game and had a normal halftime show it'd
be perfectly fine for families and
children but it only becomes
inappropriate when you again go out of
your way
wait wildly out of your way to make an
objection well my point is don't do that
don't do it it's it's it's it's kind of
it's egregious it's pointless I mean I
understand the point the point is is
about rating so I get that but that is
the point it's a cynical point but
there's this
they're still I mean ethically it just
it's I don't think it's the right
decision you they have every right to do
it I don't say they don't have a right
to they have a right to do it I'm saying
it's the wrong thing to do they have a
right to it but it is not the right
thing to do
and when they do they're taking away
this space from kids not the kids have a
god-given right to it that's not my
point putting that at the rights aside I
I think a football game should be a
space for kids and families that's it my
podcast on the other hand should that be
a space for kids I don't see any reason
why it needs to be or should be there
are millions of podcasts out there you
know you have to go and seek this one
out and if your kid is interested in
podcasts well they can there they can
surely find one that works for them it's
different from the Super Bowl which is a
game broadcast to billions of people at
a time something that literally the
whole world participates in almost at
some level so turning that into a nod a
non kid-friendly space is very different
from me turning this little old podcast
into a non kid-friendly space
you see the the difference between those
two things
I'm flattered by the comparison that you
think this podcast is as relevant and
you know pervasive as the Super Bowl but
I can assure you that it is not to put
it mildly and we will leave it there but
thank you for the email thanks everybody
for watching and listening Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey supervising
producer Mathis Glover supervising
producer Robert Stirling technical
producer Austin Stephens editor Donovan
Fowler audio mixer Robin Fenderson the
Matt Walsh show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20 if
you want to cut through the madness of
our politics and culture and know what's
really going on head on over to the
Michael Noel's show where we can all
bask in the simple joys of being right
see you there
[Music]